wir kommen zur aktuellen sitzung zum
seminar
wie immer gibt es zunächst einen
rückblick auf die letzte sitzung in der
hatten wir das thema ästhetik von
künstliche intelligenz das ist ein ganz
spannendes thema warum immer mehr
beispiele im alltag zeigen uns dass
künstliche intelligenz nicht nur ein
reines hilfsmittel ist ein technisches
instrument das künstliche intelligenz
immer mehr in und mit unserem alltag
erwogen wird und das zeigt sich eben
auch im bereich der ästhetik das heißt
die menschen maschine interaktion die
wir im vergangenen sitzung behandelt
hatten die kann eben auch unter
ästhetischen gesichtspunkten betrachtet
werden es handelt sich dabei
gewissermaßen ästhetische inter
objektivität ich habe diesen begriff
warum eines anderen seminars philosophie
der digitalität war eingeführt oben
rechts mehr richtung link zu diesem
seminar zu dieser sitzung ein
kunstschaffende
künstlerinnen und künstler jeglicher
couleur jeglicher kunstrichtungen und
künstliche intelligenz verhalten sich
die machen mich wie subjekt und objekt
oder wie subjekt instrument das wäre zu
instrumentalist ish das scheint mir für
die bedeutung die philosophische
bedeutung von keine zu kurz zu greifen
sie nur als ein instrument zu sehen
vielmehr bilden sie einen zusammenhang
durchaus einen kreativen zusammenhang im
sinne virtuelle kunst produktionen
künstliche intelligenz wird
gewissermaßen zu einer virtuellen muse
zu einer virtuellen inspirationsquelle
durch die möglichkeit der modifikation
variationen transformation allerdings
immer vorgegebenen datenmaterials also
ganz originell ganz genial ganz kreativ
kann ki so meine ich nie sein sie müssen
immer diese maßen hypothetisch als immer
unter der bedingung gegebenen materials
ansetzen kann dann aber ganz
erstaunliche
ergebnisse zu tage fördern die für einen
künstler oder eine künstlerin als
inspiration dienen können künstliche
intelligenz ist also nicht als solche
kreativ aber sie lässt sie in kreative
prozesse als einen moment integrieren
das ist mir ganz wichtig als ein moment
das heißt nicht nur als ein instrument
ist als ein bestandteil eines
umfassenderen prozesses der natürlich
immer auch zwischen künstlerin und kam
in einer wechselwirkung besteht also es
geht nicht nur in eine richtung sondern
wirkt auch von der calida zurück zum
künstler künstliche intelligenz keine
überraschung neue perspektiven erzeugen
die als inspiration für unser
kunstschaffen gehen können das ist jetzt
noch recht allgemein zusammengefasst ich
komme noch einmal auf beispiele zu
sprechen hier hatten wir erst mal ein
porträt das auf basis von 15.000
historischen porträts von ki erstellt
wurde anhand eines interessanten
algorithmus eines interessanten
verfahren und dann haben wir jetzt
dieses beethoven ex die zehnte sinfonie
von beethoven die durch den einsatz von
künstlicher intelligenz aber auch mit
menschlicher hilfe zu ende gebracht
wurde und ganz interessante
akustischen qualitäten aufweist ich
mache auch oben rechts den weg zu der
letzten sitzung waren wo sie dann hier
auf ein hörbeispiel bekommen können das
finden sie natürlich auch im internet
auf youtube zum beispiel dann habe ich
kurz ein buch vorgestellt kürzen warum
kunst und künstliche intelligenz welche
sich sehr
relevant finden für die aktuelle debatte
das buch ist erschienen im rahmen einer
neuen reihe die heißt keine kritik finde
ich auch spannend animus auch kritisiert
werden kritik bedeutet jetzt aber nicht
geschlecht zu finden oder zu verdammen
sondern vielleicht ihrem sinne von kant
also die bedingungen und möglichkeiten
zu ermessen unter denen kann überhaupt
eingesetzt werden kann also nicht
karriere als solche sind immer noch den
ganzen hintergrund versuchen krim zu
bestimmen vor dem auftritt und sie zu
prüfen die ki was kann sie
was kann sie nicht wie sollten wir
darüber reden das ist ein kritischer
zugang das kann uns im alltag immer mehr
bestandteil werden wird und nicht mehr
wegzudenken ist das ist klar die frage
ist nur wie ki in unseren alltag
einfließen zahlt natürlich auch eine
normative frage die die praktische
philosophie betrifft
in der heutigen sitzung geht es jetzt
aber emotionale künstliche intelligenz
die jetzt war mit ekg
abgekürzt habe hier gibt es ein buch was
jetzt total ist nämlich von katrin
wisselsheim künstliche intelligenz und
empathie vom leben mit emotionserkennung
sex roboter und co ein spannendes thema
und ich lese hier mal zwei zitate voraus
dieses buch ganz zentrale der begriff
der emotional künstliche intelligenz auf
englisch auch effektiv computing wurde
in den 1990 er jahren im zuge der
debatte um die emotionale intelligenz
geprägt sie lässt sich analog zur
künstlichen intelligenz als diejenige
disziplin definieren dies mit der
nachbildung oder simulationen von
emotionen zu tun hat also damit ob und
wie künstliche systeme emotionen
erkennen ausdrücken und vielleicht sogar
selbst auf wanzen können jetzt wollen
sie sich folgende fragen es ist jetzt
hier die frage
ob wir jetzt künstliche emotionale
intelligenz im sinne einer bloßen
modulation verstehen
sind einer duplikation ich darf noch mal
an dieses seminar erinnern
von john c ich mache auch um rechts die
linke ein wo er auch die frage
aufgeworfen hat wird jetzt hier kw
simuliert oder wird sie dupliziert
applicationmanager das ist auch
natürlich bei allen touring noch
zentraler der diese begriffe auch schon
eingeführt hat und die stellt sich auch
hier also
simulieren künstliche emotionale
intelligenz nur emotionen oder
publizieren sie also realisieren sie
tatsächlich emotionen noch ein zitat die
notwendigkeit emotionaler karriere ups
aus der einsicht dass emotionen eine
wichtige rolle für intelligentes
verhalten spielen so gibt es neuere
wissenschaftliche evidenz dafür dass
emotionale störungen aufgrund von
hirnverletzungen zu irrationalem
verhalten führen das kann selbst dann
vorkommen wenn die kognitiven
fähigkeiten im engeren sinn die sich
durch einen klassischen eco test waren
lassen nicht beeinträchtigt wurden also
es gibt seit einiger zeit die erkenntnis
die sich immer mehr durchsetzt dass
intelligenz und revolutionen nicht so
streng wenn man dafür verschieden sind
sein dass sie in einer wechselwirkung
stehen das natürlich auch eine
psychologische frage stellung in falls
sollte man intelligenz und emotionen
nicht in ein starkes
oppositions verhältnis bringen sondern
sie sind aufeinander verwiesen ich
glaube das hat vermittelt kathrin horn
jetzt sehr zu recht
beschrieben und sie hat jetzt in ihrem
buch eine tabelle entwickelt eine
klassifikation
zwischen
verschiedenen affektiven phänomenen wie
sie sie nennt emotionen stimmungen
empfindung charakterzüge und zwischen
verschiedenen merkmalen diese hier in
der senkrechten spalte
und hier gibt es verschiedene kriterien
zum beispiel vielleicht das wichtigste
was die kognition kognitive dimension
betrifft das ist die intention ali-t
also die gerichte auf etwas und sie sagt
jetzt nur emotionen von allen effektiven
phänomen weise nur emotionen intentional
i tät auf
empfindung nicht stimmungen auch nicht
das ist eine interessante
klassifizieren ich würde dem zustimmt
oder auch sagen dass emotionen
sicherlich die komplexesten effektiven
phänomen wie sich sie ihn endlich bin
mit dieser zeichnung effektive phänomen
nicht ganz zufrieden kommt gleich noch
mehr darauf zu sprechen ohne frage haben
emotionen wie auch stimmungen wie auch
empfindungen subjektiv erlebnisqualität
ist quartier
bieten jetzt
nur emotionen zu körperlichen
veränderungen führen
und nicht immer wenn eine empfindung das
kann man sicherlich diskutieren hat
sicherlich sind emotionen stärker als
stimmungen und
manifestieren sich dementsprechend auch
stärker körperlich
wie sieht es mit empfindungen aus und
wie sieht es mit effekten aus diese hier
gar nicht
einbezogen hat weil sie effekte als
überbegriff versteht hier habe ich einen
anderen vorschlag einer anderen
klassifikation einfach als hintergrund
von uns heute debatte wie man emotionen
und andere verwandte phänomene
zueinander ordnen kann und zwar habe ich
diese klassifikation im rahmen eines
seminars gemacht haben über
philosophische evolutionstheorie nicht
nach oben rechts den link zur playlist
dieses seminares rein aus dem letzten
sommersemester
und ich habe hier eine andere
klassifikation gegeben auch allein schon
durch die ordnung hier ist nämlich jetzt
im vertikalen
die verschiedenen typen die phänomene
angeordnet und im horizontalen die
kategorien und ich glaube wir können
zwischen emotionen gefühle effekten und
stimmungen unterschied also was jetzt
sich ändert gegenüber dem schema von
kathrin missel horn ist dass ich hier
noch effekte mit einbeziehen mich sind
effekte kann überbegriff für emotionen
gefühle und stimmungen sie sind ein fall
von ja was auch immer von
von
innerlichen zuständen die man jetzt so
oder so beschreiben kann und ich glaube
dass man hier eine andere unterscheidung
zu grunde legen kann nämlich die wie
fern inwiefern wie intensiv unsere
subjektivität betroffen ist und zwar ob
sie eben ganz betroffen ist oder nur
partiell
und mir scheint dass emotionen uns ganz
in beschlag nehmen
bislang hatte deswegen ja auch dafür
argumentiert dass emotionen sich
körperlich zeigen im gegensatz zu
anderen verwandten phänomen dem würde
ich auch zustimmen aber ich würde hier
eben noch sagen der effekt der kann sie
eben auch körperlich zeiten zum beispiel
der wut in der die wut ist sicherlich
keine emotionen sind ein effekt wenn wir
affekte und emotionen verwandten
unterscheiden
und der unterschied zwischen
effekt und emotionen ist aber dir das
perfekte nur vorübergehend stattfinden
und keine wirklich ausdehnung die
extension sie verfallen sehr schnell und
das scheint mir bei emotionen nicht der
fall zu sein weil zum beispiel achtung
die als emotion gilt auch liebe die kann
tragfähiger seien die kann man sich
länger erstrecken wo hingegen nicht
während der hass neben schon also hast
wäre auch ein beispiel für eine emotion
glaube weil er sich länger erstrecken
kann weil er aber auch wie der effekt
sehr intensiv sein kann hingegen müssen
wir noch die stimmen davon unterscheiden
die eben
auch sehr ausgedehnt ist die aber nicht
so sehr uns in beschlag und bis der
effekt oder die emotionen tut also das
ist ein alternatives modell ich will
damit nicht sagen dass es der anderen
überlegen ist ich will nur sagen hier
kann man treffen darüber streiten vor
allem was die rolle von effekten angela
und wir sehen dass emotionen
ausgezeichnet sind warum darum geht es
mir eigentlich jetzt emotionen bild auf
diesem schema hier eine schnittmenge und
zwar von
motivation und von reflexion damit meine
ich die emotionen haben wie effekt eine
innere energie eine stärke eine in der
psychische triebkraft die uns auch
motivieren kann zu handeln stimmungen
hingegen sind wie ich glaube zu schwach
stimmungen können uns nur stück sehr
schlecht zur handlung motivieren das
heißt wir haben ja die motivation ahles
element was emotionen mit alten teilen
aber im gegensatz zu perfekten besitzen
emotionen auch noch sein reflexive
moment warum weil sie in ihrer
ausdehnung sich erstrecken und nicht nur
vorübergehend stattfinden im affekt wer
im affekt handelte er ist häufig nicht
ganz zurechnungsfähig de htm fehlt ein
bisschen die reflexion der kann sich
nicht dazu verhaltens und er geht ganz
in diesem effekt auf ist fast schon
getrieben oder fremdgesteuert das ist
bei der achtung bei der liebe wenn man
lieber jetzt als emotion versteht nicht
der fall das heißt hier bekommt mehr die
reflexion zum spielen und diese
schnittmenge zwischen motivation ahler
und reflexiv war leicht kognitiver
dimensionen kattrin michel hat spricht
von der internationalität die würde ich
auch mutter zu nehmen die zeichnet eben
gerade emotionen aus ja das ist so ein
vorschlag zur klassifikation jetzt komme
auf die leitfragen der heutigen sitzung
zu sprechen was ist unter künstlicher
emotionaler intelligenz zu verstehen
hier stellt sich natürlich auch die
frage wie wir künstlich verstehen müssen
ist es nur eine simulation oder ist es
vielleicht sogar eine publikation eine
realisierung inwiefern kann kalli unsere
emotionen erkennen
es ist also eine konkretere fragen die
auch die mensch-maschine-interaktion
jetzt nicht unter ästhetischen sondern
und da beim effektiven gesichtspunkten
betrachtet und schließlich worin
bestehen die ethischen probleme von
künstlicher
emotionaler intelligenz gibt es ja auch
spezifische probleme die
künstliche ethische
intelligenz künstlich emotionale
intelligenz betrifft ja das sind die
fragen für die heutige sitzung ich bin
sehr gespannt auf die diskussion und
stoppe jetzt die auszeichnung